so we've been talking for a while now I
mean really since the January 6th riots
uh about the different stories that
those who want to excuse what happened
on that day have been telling about what
took place many of these stories you've
heard before it wasn't really trumpists
in other words it was antifa in Disguise
or people pretending to be trumpists or
in direct conflict with that it was
trumpous but they weren't violent it was
peaceful
obviously those two can't both be true
but these are examples of conflicting
explanations for what took place or a
few people did the wrong thing and it
was less about politics but more about
those people being unhinged or whatever
and they should be punished but not too
too bad because for political reasons
they're being held without bail and it's
all too strict and the conditions aren't
good and one guy didn't get vegan food
and so on and so forth so there's been
all these different stories told the FBI
set it up Tucker Carlson played with
that one for a little while
Gonna Play a clip for you here which is
kind of like the next iteration the next
step in the evolution of this and this
is a clip of Newsmax host Greg Kelly uh
suggesting that Democrats set up the
riots and maybe even carried them out
maybe in some general sense Democrats
set the conditions for the riots but
maybe they actually just planned it they
they did it they did the whole thing so
let's just go to this clip I'm going to
play a couple minutes of it because even
the lead up is crazy again this is on
Newsmax this is really wacky weaponized
stuff let's get into it I loved it I
love the trolley I love King Friday he's
going to show up eventually I loved it
as a child as a four to seven year old
child and occasionally in college look
the Land of Make Believe is for children
it is not for adults but we are in Joe
Biden's America they want us to live in
the land of make believe they're going
to pretend imagine
smearing Mr Rogers in order to make this
very ridiculous political Point pretend
that black children aren't being killed
by other black children okay now this is
the black on black violence myth what do
I mean it's a myth are black people
killed by black people yeah
when you look at the actual data the
odds of a black person being being
killed by a black person are within a
couple percentage points
of the odds of a white person being
killed by a white person we still have a
relatively segregated country and people
overall are around people like them and
thus are likely to be victimized by
people that are like them for years
we've known this they don't care this is
happening this is happening and it can't
be denied this is a crisis yet
no one wants to talk about it no one
wants to talk about this it is happening
and nothing is being done it has become
so bad under Joe Biden because well he's
in so much denial how about this the
crime wave the conventional crime I'm
talking about robberies everywhere
shootings and robberies you know black
lives matter the summer last year it led
to all kinds of help yourself to
anything you want in the store consider
how unhinged this is by the way these
are all unrelated issues that he wants
to put together as Biden caused all of
it it's racist to make an arrest or even
call the cops this is bad bad stuff so
in the Land of Make Believe Joe Biden's
land none of this stuff is happening but
what is happening the scourge of white
supremacy yes white supremacy is
responsible for all this stuff we had to
go back quite some way to find uh
footage of this white supremacy does
exist now for people who are looking you
know he's making fun of we have to go
back to 1925 to show a rally of white
supremacists of course this whatever
degree of of problem you believe white
supremacy is today with the Advent of
the internet social media and other
types of communication
you don't need parades you know not
everything that lacks a parade doesn't
exist I think is the point that we
should be taking from this are some
idiots who believe in that and they're
off in the woods somewhere knock
yourselves out don't break the law and
if you do well you should be arrested
here we go now um January 6 is another
fixture in the Land of Make-Believe that
this was the worst thing that ever
happened not that it was a trespassing
event not that Democrats may have had a
hand in setting the conditions and even
perhaps setting the whole thing up whoa
there's something to talk about there
all right all this stuff is going on all
the other stuff is not going on but
they're saying it's going on okay so he
just kind of goes into completely wacky
delusional stuff at this point in time
so this is this is the next iteration
where they've tried to blame everyone
other than themselves however
when they blame democrats for the
insurrection
they're admitting there was an
Insurrection right like should we
consider that a victory to some degree
but this is another layer as to why as
I've been saying earlier this week these
folks have to be held accountable and
when I when I say that I mean the
Insiders need to be voted out of office
in 2022. they're not going to be many of
the Insiders are in dark red districts
and there's no chance that they're voted
out it's just not going to happen but we
need there to be consequences number one
in order to be able to say here are the
people it's not Democrats it's this list
of people who rioted and they've been
found guilty and sentenced and it's this
list of people in the House and Senate
and they've lost their seats we're not
going to get that not to the degree that
I would hope but it's what we would need
in order to undeniably be able to push
back against these horrible narratives
that are being created like maybe
Democrats not only set up the conditions
but actually set up the entire thing
there's a contingent that won't care
does a contingent that will always
believe it was antifa or it was peaceful
trumpists or would they're never going
to believe it but we want to be chipping
away and having something really
specific to say no it wasn't Democrats
not a single Democratic member of
Congress or whatever these were
trumpists they were prosecuted they were
found guilty they were they were
sentenced these are the elected
officials who did it and I I wish I
could say I was confident that we were
going to get that
I don't think that we are I I still
don't think that we are to the degree
that we really need it if you think
we're going to get those consequences
let me know when and how you think we're
going to get them because I don't think
that mostly the slaps on the wrist that
we're seeing right now
um are cutting it and we'll see there
are still many cases pending